[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and now
your money will no more go into the
public execution
that points yourself a little blackberry
and national guard i know you watch me
i'm gonna tell you something right now i
hope
that you're sleeping take your last
house
i hope they treat you better than they
change your comrades over in d.c
does it mean i'm sleeping with floors
i don't know let the peace team be over
here
all the way in from rogers
out there i'll be in here for a long
time because it's gonna be a scoop over
how long we're gonna be out here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
been out here
[ __ ]
okay
oh
is
until i changed it
[Music]
is
he was responsible
period period period
and then when we were at the press
conference yesterday
asking who was the cop who murdered
dante they tried to tell us they
couldn't release that information
we said the devil is a liar you will
release that information
that is public data she wasn't walking
around anonymous
when she was driving from champlain to
the city of brooklyn park
looking center she wasn't anonymous then
but she was pulling people over for some
damn air freshener
hanging on their mirror she wasn't
anonymous
when she pretended that she was stuck
her gun for a danger so we said you're
not going to be anonymous today who will
argue
the truth came out kim potter
was on the chopping block to be
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and that's what we said to the mayor of
brooklyn center
that she needs to be fired i hope the
city council is listening
she needs to be fired i hope the post
board is listening
she needs to be fired and her license to
remain as a police officer
needs to be stripped away because
clearly she
[Music]
and our black women and our indigenous
men and our indigenous women and
children in danger
hell no
[Music]
some change has happened since we have
been out here
on sunday but it's not the end of the
story
we want to stop police from killing
black people we're people indigenous
people
mom people people with disabilities
[Music]
and if you're not capable of treating
people with dignity
go find
[Music]
we were just on a call with governor
walker before we got here there's other
organizers on their way because we put
forward nine bills to the legislature
anything qualified immunity is an
example yeah
professional liability insurance so that
they can stop
killing people on the taxpayers dollars
so it's a bunch of bills that we are
demanding we want
an independent body to investigate
police killing and not the bureau of
criminal apprehension
because they might as well be the bureau
of criminals
because there's cops investigating and
they
rubber stem police
[Music]
because he should still be alive
so we have to continue to stay vigilant
we cannot be intimidated
we can't back up we can't back down we
got to keep fighting for justice
black lives matter thank god for being
out here so
next what i want to do is call up a
sister who comes here very frequently
from chicago illinois this woman just
flew in this morning
and as soon as she got to my house i
said we gotta get to brooklyn center
city hall for a press conference and if
you watch the press conferences
police department and this woman kim
handy jones
she's the one that came up with the chat
and she's well i got my food song today
we're here we're here to shut this [ __ ]
down
that's our chick give it up for kim
handy joe
[Applause]
my name is
i come here
one of them
today
but it's hard for a black woman a black
mother
to sit at home and let these killings
continuously keep
my son's spirit pushes me
and when my feet hit the floor my boots
is on the ground
i'm sick and tired of these emergency
ass
cops killing our kids
you 26 years
on a police course and you mean to tell
me you want more a taser from a [ __ ]
gun
i bet you you know a black man from a
white one
and she
[Music]
for years and years
and then sometimes you know
[Music]
oh
for what
[Music]
and even though we peacefully do what we
do it don't save our kids
please don't do that i come from chicago
i'm just coming through
i got to do what i got to do and that
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] youtube
[Applause]
and a lot of these [ __ ] feel
like they deserved it
how the hell did the jury to be dead
and he wasn't a uh obese young man he
was small inside
he wasn't armed
he was trying to get in the top talking
to his mama
but you know what a lot of air questions
we got to do what the [ __ ] we got to do
but you expect us to live
[Music]
12.
[Music]
ain't no more
on the ground
[Music]
is
and the bible says
[Music]
okay
notice he was living longer than he was
living but guess what
when he wasn't even a seed in his mama
belly
she was on the fourth six years
[Music]
if you got kids and you don't got kids
we can't wait for the next time
we gotta keep marching keep protesting
keep rallying every time
every day and we don't get no justice
if we don't get no justice
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
because you have a fortune that me and a
lot of people like me don't have
you get to go home and wrap your arms
around your babies
your wife your mama your daddy
i can't wrap my arms around my child
and took that from me
and since you acting that's like the
[ __ ] you care
i'm sick of it i am sick and tired of it
and then they have a nerve to sit here
and look at this dog
now that jim kind
worry
because you know what they claim that
they wear
these video cameras on their chest
the transparency what if it's about
transparency
why don't you all let us see the video
that's not only clear but it clears that
person if
i'm sick of it
so you know you get mad about what the
what the people say
and words to kill you'll be dead
otherwise you'll never kill nobody
but you all are taking out [ __ ]
blocks contagious
and killing these threats around here
it ain't gonna never be right and let
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
for me i'm not going to sit and drive in
my opinion
i'm not going to stick with something
i'm not feeling like the business of
myself and my daughters
you know my brothers and my sisters
let me tell you something
[Music]
one foot
[Music]
we're here
there is a curfew in effect in
minneapolis and city hall but not here
in brooklyn
you can see behind me there's already
several hundred protesters
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
give it up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
will be filed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
we just not out here showing up and
convenient
and being in space we're sending a very
clear clearing call out into the
universe
and then some of us is taking you the
collective energy
that y'all see all around you right now
and translating that
into policy and going inside of
buildings like that
and that city hall over there and we are
dealing with everything
[Music]
of people don't stop yeah i think kim
just nicely put forward a resignation
but she just did she feel bad
is she just was she said was she just
[Music]
he
[Music]
let me break down the scientific facts
here
now what they think is that they're
going to put in
these resignations which thereby
allows them to still collect upon their
pictures
and so now the second stage of this
is to make sure that this mayor rejects
those letters of resignation why what do
we want
where do we want it what do we want how
do we want it
reject that level of resignation and
dominate her
she needs to be fired step one step one
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now
okay
you're not just out here for a while
[Music]
we're doing that for him we still have
elon
and that we [ __ ] now right now we need
you
don't tell us now make it happen
bother your heart
there's
[Music]
that's what we expect that is
[ __ ] down
[Applause]
[Music]
i want to introduce somebody to you who
has been
who's been out here uh since their
nephew marcus golden
was over the exit was killed by cops
and he's been out in the streets since
doing the work
leading the way paving the road and
being the example
of spinning inspiration to many i want
y'all to give it up for monique
[Music]
callisto
[Music]
this is what it takes and i appreciate
all of you so
very much this is what we have done is
what we will continue to do so we have
to understand that if we let up
and we will let there be a way every
time this happens
so it's so important that we do not get
tired that we not
get scared we will not be intimidated
but we continue
we want the ability to move and to
thrive we want the same things that we
feed our white male turn up ourselves we
want everything
that they have we want everything that
america has freely handed out
to people of others
as descendants of insane african people
as the native people have been so we
want to make sure
that we are not just standing up for one
individual
we are standing up for all those who
have died before
[Music]
members whether they know that person or
not
it has an impact and it ripples through
our soul
and through our hearts so we have to
remember
all of those who have come before all
the blood that's on the ground all the
blood that's in the automobile
that shed law enforcement and just as
they have continued to train
their police officers sending them over
to israel getting militarized
tactics and training we're getting
better too
so remember that we've got a better
system than we've ever had before
we're able to better protect our people
and we're out here with these streets we
have better style we have better
equipment we got better marshals better
motorcycles
so we're getting better too right
yesterday i saw people out with
umbrellas
people out with deep blowers that's what
we needed
[Music]
to continue to show up and act like our
lives do not matter
because we know it's not about the
actions
police officers
and we have to demand it and we just
demand them
that's not gonna do what we want because
we can't continue to take this
so we saw ryan who saw the fires and
george floyd
and of course it took that fight to give
them a challenge
remember that what happened
and
back in november
oakdale in front of their children's
house and arrested
i was involved right we want to make
sure that we're standing up and
continuing to stand up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
give it up for the president of the
nwacp minneapolis
[Music]
raise your hand if you ever had
he's
[Music]
when you don't get a review they find
you another range of revenue
when they arrest you they find you
another way for revenue
when they kill you they can pay no
matter what
they are benefiting off of ourselves
this change benefit of us being
hyper police over police
the city of minneapolis 16 are drivers
the 40 of the 40 of the traffic stops
are african-american
[Music]
it ain't great the police they stay
up in rondo neighborhood in north
minneapolis and south minneapolis
you're gonna like those plans because
they know that okay we can pull them
over
look up their names and if they got
something out of school we can fight
oh we can arrest them and get more money
[Music]
their school their housing complexes
and their time their homes
[Music]
well our communities got tough goals
[Music]
[Music]
oh
pizza
system
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
one of the most energetic one of the
most
high energy brothers i've seen speak out
[Music]
here
[Music]
uh
[Music]
oh it's my battery you got one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so okay you just you just need a shotgun
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my hand can i pop up here are you
stepping out again yeah i'll step out
you could probably just hold it i just
want to step on the show
oh um
[Music]
what do
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
if we don't get no clusters
[Music]
[Music]
one of the tallest shining shoes
uh
hey paul and jackie for about an hour or
so demonstrators have been
marching very little but they are
stationed outside the police department
they are
chanting dante wright's name they are
calling for justice
and right now community leaders are
stepping up to the microphone to share
the message
to share messages for the crowd uh in
just the last minute or so
representative john thompson
for a few minutes and i'll step out to
give you a scope of how many people are
here
easily more than 100 and we're probably
getting close to
that hundreds mark again they're calling
for justice for dante right they're
calling for meaningful legislation
they're also calling more to be done
surrounding officer potter demonstrators
calling the resignation not enough
they're also calling for charges to be
set a couple other speakers
include the minneapolis naacp president
as well and other community members who
are part of organizations
that we have seen throughout this year
calling for justice for of course george
floyd
other people across america and now for
dante wright
again this was scheduled to be a march
but it was just a small march they just
walked the length of the police
department and that is where they are
stationed now there is a couple of
speakers set up community leaders now
taking the time
to share messages with the community
another thing they
made mention of is they have no plans on
leaving you know the curfew is now set
for brooklyn center at 10 o'clock
but again they said they have no plans
on leaving until
what they're calling for is done we're
live in brooklyn center ben henry
witness news
people do not get incarcerated by
[Music]
accidents
country incarcerates more people
foreign
you
you
you
um
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
for sure
[Music]
all
[Music]
[Music]
maybe you can uh me
[Music]
everybody stay behind this justice for
don't say white banner
so folks know what we're here for to
stay behind the banner
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Laughter]
do
happy
so
so
[Laughter]
so
so
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
we're here
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
just shake yeah
[Music]
[Music]
good times
we're here
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
way
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
all my sisters will be free
[Applause]
[Music]
right
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
all
is
[Music]
what's up
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
we
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
the [ __ ] people
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
right
[Music]
okay
y'all know where we are
we gotta go
[Music]
check check check ben henry my chat
[Music]
i haven't heard anything
hold on
[Music]
okay
[Music]
like
foreign
you've got
[Music]
okay i'm gonna
maybe just go with whatever you see
yeah i got you conrad
i'm gonna step on this
we'll go here i'll reference the
building where where we're at practice
real quick
okay fbi blah
i want you to walk with me out there
okay
okay
[Music]
everything
[Music]
i wonder what i guess
[Music]
and you know what you gonna do
[Music]
[Music]
amazon